>> Good morning everyone.
So, it's my very great
pleasure to introduce
Kartik Nayak from
the University of Maryland.
At the moment, he's
a fifth year PhD student
under Prof. Katz and Prof. Shi.
And he's been a recipient
of a Google Fellowship
in Security,
and he'll be talking to us
today Oblivious Computation.
>> All right.
Good morning everyone.
I'm very excited to be here.
Today, I'll be talking
about how to use
oblivious computation
to compute in
private data and to
obfuscate programs.
And towards the end, I'll
talk a little bit more about
my research in general and some
of my ongoing and future work.
So, it is if you have
the scenario where we
have two or more
hospitals, and together,
they're trying to compute
information of that type,
is some treatment better
than some other treatment?
And they want to
do this based on
the joint information of all
the hospitals
patient data put together.
But laws, such as
HIPAA, do not allow
one hospital to share its data
with another hospital.
So, you have the scenario where
you have your input data which
is patient data that is private,
and yet you're trying to
perform some computation
on top of this,
and the computation
itself may be public.
You have a complementary
scenario where you have
companies such as 23andMe which
have patented
genomic algorithms.
And they want to send
their programs to the end user,
in such a way that
the end user can
find its own
ancestry information.
In this scenario, 23andMe
wants end users to
use their program,
yet not learn what
the program is doing
because the program forms
the trade secret
for such companies.
So, you have a dual scenario.
You're aware
a program is private,
but the user input themselves
may or may not be public.
So, my research has
focused on designing and
building systems for such
privacy-preserving computation.
And as I just mentioned,
broadly it falls
into two categories.
One, how to secretly
outsource data and
enable computation on it.
And second, how to
obfuscate programs.
And today, I'm going
to discuss this with
the lens of access-pattern
Obliviousness,
which in a nutshell is
the art of hiding
memory access patterns.
And to start today,
I'm going to first
discuss access-pattern
Obliviousness,
and this is going to be
a short introduction
to what it is.
And then I'll move on
to contributions on
computation on private data
and finally,
obfuscation of programs.
And towards the end, I'll
talk a little bit more about
my other research on
block chains and some of
my ongoing and future work.
So, whenever some computation
is being performed,
you have a CPU and memory,
where your memory will store
your data and your program,
and whenever an instruction is
being executed on
the address and database,
you will have the
corresponding memory location
that is being accessed
and the data would.
If I were to enable
computation in private data,
the first step would be
to keep this data private.
And one way to achieve
this is to leverage
a secure processor,
which ensures that
all the data in your memory is
encrypted and the data on
the database is also encrypted.
But what it still do revealed
is which memory location
you're accessing.
Such secure processors exists
in the form of Intel SGX.
But the question is,
you're still revealing
these addresses and whether
it is okay to do that.
If you look at this
specific example which says,
if some secret variable is true,
then I'm going to access
memory location X,
otherwise I'm going to
access memory location Y.
And just based on which memory
location is being accessed,
now you would know exactly what
the secret variable is.
And this tells you that,
well, access patterns can
indeed reveal
some secret information.
And if this seems
like a toy example,
there exist model level attacks,
actually this attack is
right from the MassArt lab
where some competition
was being performed on
JPEG images and this was
done using Intel SGX.
And in the process, just by
looking at base level
access patterns,
one could recover the image
to the right from
the image to the left.
And this tells you
access patterns can
indeed leak a lot of
information about your data.
And all of these attacks
are a little of the recent.
The problem of protecting
access patterns was discussed on
three decades ago
when Bullrich and
Ostrovsky came up with
the notion of an oblivious RAM,
which is a
cryptographic primitive
to provably hide
access patterns to data.
In this talk today, it
is not necessary for you
to understand an oblivious
and a schema as such,
but just to give
you some intuition,
here's what all
oblivious RAM schemes do.
Let us say I want to access
memory location five,
then an old RAM scheme would
access memory location five,
but in addition, it would
make a couple more of
a few more obfuscating accesses
to the human location
seven and two.
And once I perform this access,
what most of what RAM schemes do
is, they shuffle data around.
The reason why you shuffle
this data is because,
if you do not shuffle it and
if you want to
access five again,
then you may reveal some sort of
frequency or
co-location information.
But if you shuffle
data around, perhaps,
if you're still
accessing five again,
you would be able to hide which
memory location
you're accessing.
And because you are
making these obfuscating
accesses and shuffling data,
you actually end up touching
more memory locations than you
need and one key metric that
you're trying to reduce in
an oblivious RAM scheme,
is bandwidth blow
up or the number of
memory locations that
is being accessed.
And typically,
oblivious RAM schemes
have a point of
logarithm bandwidth blow up.
So, given this background,
one key challenge in this space
is to make access
pattern Obliviousness
efficient and this
we need to do given
that we know that there is
a lower bound that says,
if I have N passive memory
locations, by passive I mean,
you can only read and
write to this memory,
then you need to encode
at least a logarithmic overhead
for every access.
And the base of the logarithm
over here is the number of
registers stored in the CPU.
So, given this lower bound,
one thing that you can do is you
can design a scheme that
actually meets this lower bound
with as good constants as
possible or try to circumvent
this lower bound all together
by changing the assumptions
involved in the lower bound.
Second, whenever I have to
move to performing
a large amount of competition,
I would want to
parallel my computation,
and turns out parallelism with
Obliviousness comes up with
its own set of challenges.
For example, now the
communication pattern in between
the processors should not
reveal any more information.
And this constraint
is in addition to
the standard constraints of
pattern programming where you
would want to have
a low processing time
and low communication
between processors.
And finally, I would argue
whenever you want
to design a system,
you would want to design it with
some practical
constraints in mind.
For example, if I'm trying
to use a secure processor,
I should know exactly what
properties such a secure
processor it provides,
and that is useful both for
security and efficiency.
For instance, one question
that you may ask is can
the trusted processes store
stated in between locations.
Let us start to ask
this question to Intel SGX.
So, whenever Intel SGX is
executing some instruction,
it has context of
the previous instruction
it has executed.
So, in that sense,
you can think of such a process
as being stateful.
But more recently,
you have seen attacks,
called as rollback attacks,
where you could switch
off an Intel SGX machine
and then provide it with
an old state and then
rollback execution.
So, in that sense,
you can think of
Intel SGX as being
a stateless processor.
And in the second part
of my talk,
I'm going to discuss how
such exceptions in
conjunction with
Obliviousness can actually
matter in security of schemes.
But more generally, I would say
that if privacy preserving
competition were
to be a success,
it is essential for the
field of cryptography,
architecture, systems,
and programming
languages to work
in conjunction.
With that, let me move on to
discussing my contributions
towards computation
in private data,
and specifically,
I'm going to talk
about a Secure Graph-parallel
Framework, called GraphSC.
And in this framework,
I'm going to show
how it is usable,
that is you can
design programs with
programming abstractions
that you already know,
in such a way that
this framework
converts it into
an efficient parallel execution,
and you achieve some notion of
security that I'm
going to discuss.
And you are going to
see results which say,
what took us for previously
can be performed now 20x faster.
And specifically,
let us take this as
a learning example where
let's say you have Netflix,
and Netflix wants to
compute user recommendations
on this data set.
So, this data set has
in the first column
you can see users,
in the second column you can see
movies and in
the third column you can
see what rating each user
has given to the movie.
And given this Netflix wants
to compute user recommendations,
that is for a given user,
which movie the user
may want to see next.
And even if we don't
need security over here,
one thing that Netflix
would want to do is,
given such datasets
tend to be large,
you may want to
exploit parallelism.
And just for explosiveness,
you may want to use
frameworks such as GraphLab.
And GraphLab is just one
such framework in a class of
frameworks which is
targeted for a class of
algorithms called Graph-parallel
Algorithms or
Vertex-centric programs.
The reason why they're
called Vertex-centric
programs is because
at any point in time you're
always thinking like a Vertex.
So, a Vertex in
the graph based on
its own data and data
for its neighbors
is trying to perform
some competition.
For example, you can
think of PageRank,
where the PageRank from
that page depends on
its own PageRank and the
PageRanks of other pages
that are pointing to it.
In fact, the example
that I was describing
earlier on computing
user recommendations,
can be expressed as
a bipartite graph
between users at one side
and movies at the other,
and it just represent
the rating that a user
has given to a movie.
In terms of the result
that I'm going to
discuss over here,
in general applies to all my
marketing operations as well.
So, one of the reasons why
these Graph-parallel
frameworks are nice is
because you just
need to remember
three simple abstractions
and they are called scatter,
gather and apply, and I'm
going to explain them in turn.
And remember that at
each point in time,
you need to think
of the competition
as being from
a vertex's point of view.
What would a vertex do next?
The first obstruction is
a scattered obstruction,
where every vertex
sends some data to
its neighboring edges and
the neighboring edges
update their own data.
The second abstraction
is complementary,
where overtakes aggregates data
from all of
its neighboring edges,
and the vertex may
update its own data.
So the example over here
shows are gathered vertex B.
And finally in
an apply operation,
every vertex and every edge
applies some function
to its own data.
So the example over here shows
an apply by all the vertices.
And in terms of just having
these three abstractions
is very powerful for
a large class of algorithms.
And the reason why these
Graph-parallel frameworks are
nice is because
you have usability,
you just need to express
functions using
these three abstractions,
and then these
Graph-parallel frameworks
give you efficiency and
parallelism that you can easily
use the computers
that you already have.
Given this, the goal of
GraphSC was to have a secure
Graph-parallel framework,
that is to have security
in addition to all
of these three goods,
and GraphSC gives
you exactly that.
So let us see what I mean
by security in this context.
So let us see say we have
a secured processor and
it has your graph
store encrypted,
and it is trying to
perform some computation,
let's say computing
user recommendations.
What I want in the end
is to ensure that
this computation,
it hides the data on
vertices and edges,
and second, it hides
the structure of the graph.
That is, the fact that there is
an engine between two vertices
should not be revealed.
And although I'm
explaining all of
this assuming a secured
processor over here,
later I'm going to relax
that by abstracting
the secured processor using
two different parties,
and running a second
computation protocol on it.
But for now let us assume
that we have access to
a secured processor.
>> How is the data
encrypted? So how
is this data gathered in
the first place and encrypted?
>> So, in this particular
example you can assume that
a user just submits
an encrypted data and it just
communicates with
a secured processor.
In the second computation
scenario it's going
to be used slightly different
way, or use a secret,
shares its data to non-colluding
cloud service providers.
So, this is the scenario if
we have access to
a single processor.
When we move to
multiple processors,
then we have an additional
challenge in terms
of how to split
this computation into
multiple processors,
and we still need to
ensure the same properties,
that is we want to hide
data on vertices and edges,
and hide the graph
structure, and
turns out how you parallelize it
may have an effect on how
we achieve these properties.
So given this, let
us try to see how we
can achieve this
in our scenario.
Our first strawman would be
just to use an Oblivious RAM,
and an Oblivious RAM
ensures that all access
patterns are oblivious,
and it is usable because I can
use this with
any program that I like.
But the problem
is that Oblivious
RAM constructions
tend to be sequential,
that is you cannot
easily parallelize it.
And a much more subtle
constraint that comes into
the picture is that once
your data is in an ORAM,
all subsequent accessories will
incur a poly-logarithmic word.
So, given parallelism laws,
something that Oblivious RAM
did not achieve,
let us try to
achieve parallelism,
and try to do something
weird for every vertex.
I have a secure processor
trying to perform
the computation on that vertex.
Such a solution will give
you parallelism easily.
It gives you usability
because you're still
in the GraphLab vault,
and it also gives
you efficiency,
but the problem is that this
does not give you security.
And this is because the
communication between
one processor and
another processor will reveal
information off
the existence of an edge.
One way to fix this is
to ensure that there is
an all to all communication
in between these processors,
and that you will
achieve security,
but now this would be at
a cost of V squared
communication.
One thing that
Prior Work has done,
and this was for
this specific example,
they came up with
a handcrafted computation that
achieved some notion of
efficiency and it was secure.
But the problem with
such approaches is that this
was very specific
to one algorithm,
and for every algorithm
you would have to
think ground up on how to make
it parallel and Oblivious.
And they only achieved
some partial notion of
parallelism in this case.
So given this, let us
see what our work does,
and this time I'm
going to explain
with the key idea involved
in an Oblivious Gather,
and this I'm going
to first explain
assuming a single processor,
and then I'll move on to
how to parallelize this.
And for this example
let us still
assume that we have
this bipartite graph
or let me slightly simplify
this graph so that I
can fit it on the slide.
And, you can still think of
the vertices to the left as
being users and the vertices
on the right as being movies.
And let us say we have
a very simple computation
that we are performing,
and that is how many people
watch a particular movie.
So on this vertex X in
the end you would want to
see the data too being
stored over here.
And because you are just
performing a counting operation,
the data on each of
these edges is one.
The way I'm going
to present my graph
is using a simple array,
where each cell of the array
represents either a
vertex or an edge.
For example, the first cell
over here represents vertex C,
the second cell represents
edge X and so on and so forth.
And in general all vertices
are represented
by using a yellow background.
The first step that I'm
going to do in this process
is to sort this data using
an Oblivious sort
operation in such a way
that a vertex is preceded by
all of its incoming edges.
So, you're going to see vertex X
being preceded by
just A X and B X.
An Oblivious sort operation
by definition is data oblivious,
so it does not reveal
any information about your data.
And now, in a single
sequential scan,
I can perform
my aggregation operation.
So whenever I reach an edge, I'm
going to collect data
and aggregate it,
and whenever I reach a vertex,
I'm going to deposit
that data there.
So we collected one and
one from A X and B X,
and deposited it at vertex X,
and that is the simple
aggregation operation.
So over here we are doing it
for a simple counting operation,
but in general you
can do this for
any associative and
committed to operation.
W resort operation in
principal takes E log V time,
for a graph of E edges
and V vertices.
>> So, in this computation
are you allowed
to reveal the number
of vertices,
and the number of vertices
on either side of the batch?
>> No. So this computation by
itself does not reveal
that information.
So in practice what you will
end up doing over here...
>> I'm asking where if you have
a problem with computation,
you want to hide that.
>> You want to hide that.
So the computation by
itself does not reveal it,
but what may happen is that
your input and
output structure is
such that the inputs and
outputs itself reveal
how many vertices are there.
>> Well, but in this case
I can learn the sum
of vertices and edges based
on your representation itself,
right? The input there.
>> No. So all of this data
is going to be encrypted,
so that you will not
know whether a vertex
is a vertex or an edge. It's
a little more disarranged.
>> I would know what the sum of.
>> You would know
the summation of, yes...
>> I would not know
like what's the size of
each partition is, or
how many edge is there.
>> Yes.
>> And you want to
protect that even
at the end of the computation?
>> Yes, unless the initial input
or the final output
reveals that.
Because in many cases you'll
final output may just say,
give me values of all vertices.
>> Okay, thanks.
>> So your Oblivious
sort operation over
here takes E log V time for
a graph of E edges
and V vertices,
and in practice you
would actually end up
using something
like a Bitonic sort
which equals E log
squared V time,
and the sequential scan
requires order E time,
so this requires
a total work of E log V.
One key aspect about
such an operation is that this
can be easily parallelized
when you have
multiple processors.
So let us see how we do that.
Remember the end of
an Oblivious sort?
We have a vertex preceded by
all of its incoming edges,
and in general this problem
looks like the following.
You have an array of indisposed
white and yellow cells.
>> I'm sorry.
Would you be able to
correct that little thing?
So what is output
of this computation?
>> Right now I think just
for this operation it
is just aggregated and
everything is stored encrypted.
>> Okay. So if I want
to access the output I
should know the position of my.
>> So, once you're
done with performing,
so here is what the program
is going to look like.
It would be a sequence
of scatter, gather,
and apply operations in
some particular order,
and in the end if you want for
example say data
corresponding to all vertices,
I just need to perform
an Oblivious sort
again in such a way that
the vertices are at one end
and then you can
reveal just that data.
>> Then it's okay. Fine. Thanks.
>> Okay. So in general,
your problem is going to
look like the following,
where you have an area of
indisposed white
and yellow cells.
And for every yellow cell,
you are going to
aggregate the data
in the preceding white cells.
And the goal over here is
to paralyse computation,
in such a way that each of
the processors performs
an equal amount of work.
That is, you want to
distribute the graph evenly,
so that the total amount
of work is not too high.
And in addition, you'd want
to achieve Obliviousness,
that is the
communication in between
these processors does not
reveal any information.
And we do this by dividing
the array equally in between
different processors,
so that the number
of vertices that
one processor is
responsible does not matter.
It is a submission of
vertices and edges that
a processor is responsible for.
And this is done in
such a way that a processor
is connected to logarithmically
many other processors,
and the amount of communication
in between them is logarithmic.
I'm not going to
go into the details
of exactly how this is achieved,
but this is actually
a generalization of
the more well known part, sorry.
>> Can I have a question
[inaudible] So do you do the
oblivious sort on
multiple processor?
You go for first,
or I'll just be then?
>> Yes, yes. We do it
on multiple processor.
We implement a Bitonic sort.
And because it is
a network sorting algorithm,
it's easy to do that.
So it turns out that problem
is actually a generalization
of the more well known
parallel prefix sum problem.
Then let's say you
have an input array,
and the output for
the eight element,
you would want the summation
of the first elements.
And let us say, we have
one processor
working on each set.
And this can be done easily
in logarithmic number of steps,
where in each step,
each processor is performing
some sort of divide
and conquer algorithm.
And this is being done in
sync with all of the processors.
With that, you had as well
the complexity of
these operations look like.
If you would have
used an ORAM baseline,
it would have required
E polylog V time.
Our solution for
scatter and gather
can perform it in O
over E log V time.
And for apply, it can
do it in O E V time.
And in parallel, as
I just mentioned,
the depth of
our computation is O log
V. And although I did
not mention apply,
the depth of that
computation is constrict.
So until now, I
have assumed that
we have access to a secure
processor, but turns out,
we abstract the secure processor
using two non-colluding
cloud service providers,
and we use a secure computation
protocol in between them.
So let me stick
a small detail and explain
more secure computation is,
and then let us see how we
can apply this in our setting.
So, secure computation protocol
allows two parties, or
two or more parties.
In this case,
two parties. Let's say,
one with input X and
the other with input Y.
To compute some
function f of x_y,
in such a way that one party
does not reveal its input
to the other party.
And if I have access
to such a protocol,
let us see how we can
use this in our setting.
First, for my dataset,
I can encrypt this by
just secret sharing
this in between two
non-colluding cloud
service providers.
Lets say, Netflix and Amazon.
And secret sharing ensures
that each shared by
itself does not
reveal any information
to either Netflix or Amazon,
but together, they have
all the information that is
necessary to perform
the computation.
And now, they can just run
a secure computation
protocol with
the algorithm that I
just described earlier.
And this ensures
that Netflix never
learns Amazon share,
and vice versa.
And that means, they can
learn the output without
knowing the input ahead of time.
And this ensures that
your data on vertices
and edges is hidden,
and the graph structure
results are hidden.
So for a specific
implementation,
we used Yao's garbled circuits.
And we build this
on top of FlexSC,
which is ObliVM's backend.
And ObliVM is a secure
computation framework we
were working on at that time.
In case you haven't
heard of Yao's
garbled circuit, that is fine.
It is just a secure computation
protocol that we used.
So given parallelism was
one of our key improvements,
the first thing we wanted to do
was try to run this on as
bigger computation as we can.
And we did this for the task
of computing user
recommendations.
And the algorithm
that we implemented
was sparse matrix factorization
using gradient design.
And we could do this
on a MovieLens dataset
of size one million,
where when I say one million,
I mean the number of
vertices and number of
edges in this graph
together is one million.
And the size of the computation
was about a trillion
garbled gates.
And at the time,
this was the largest
ever computation
that was performed using
secure computation.
And this would then
using 128 CPU cores,
which is what we had access
to in our lab at that time.
Comparing this to prior work,
they could do
this computation only
on size 16,000 ratings.
And for the same size
dataset using 32 CPU cores,
what took them one point for us
took us less than three
and a half minutes.
And this 20x improvement is
primarily because of the VVA
efficiently parallelism.
But in addition to parallelism,
we do this generically for
any program that can be
expressed in the
graph parallel state.
And for them, they
just handcrafted
this computation for
this specific example.
>> Can I as a question?
>> Sure.
>> If the number from
one million become 10 million,
how do the computation in
terms of CPU, memory usage?
>> So, in terms of time.
>> Time, yeah.
>> In terms of
time, it would be,
so it behaves as n locks
squared m. So it would be
almost linear but that
there would be a lock
squared component that would
also come into picture.
>> What about CPU usage
and the memory?
>> So when we implemented this,
this was CPU bound.
Right now it is communication
bound because with
newer algorithms,
newer processors have access to
ASNI because of these
computations are now faster,
and now it is
communication bound.
So in terms of
computational resources,
I'm saying it would take
that much amount of time
using the same amount
of computational
resources that we're
using over here.
If we can have higher amount
of computation of resources,
which I'm going to get to next,
then you can still have
possibly the same amount
of time depending on
how many resources you
use. So, let us see how.
>> Sorry, I didn't follow
the switch from like talking
about ORAM and
parallel computation
to secure computation.
>> Okay.
>> So, why was that necessary?
This might be
a dumb question. So, I
mean I just didn't
follow that switch.
>> Okay. So, the same
result we have apply
in both these settings.
One, where you have
a secure processor
and you're trying
to hide memory access patterns.
In terms of in
secure computation,
the problem is
slightly different
where you have a ramp program
and eventually
you want a socket.
And an important
intermediary over
here is the notion of
an oblivious program.
So, the place where this ORAM or
these oblivious algorithms
come into picture is
their design of these oblivious
algorithms which
is the hard part.
And once you have
an oblivious algorithm,
converting it into circuits is
an easy translation.
Well, I'm not sure if I.
>> Im just going to ask a sort
of related question but.
>> Sure.
>> Again.
So, when you're talking
about the oblivious sort,
for example, do you still
need ORAM or not anymore?
>> No.
>> Or you'd like custom,
or basically looking
for a good sort?
>> We are just trying
to get rid of an ORAM.
We are not using an ORAM
altogether, yeah.
>> You don't want ORAM?
>> Yeah. We are just trying
to make it oblivious,
and Obliviousness and, achieving
Obliviousness and writing
a circuit, they're synonymous.
So, once you have
the Obliviousness,
converting it into a circuit
is a one-to-one translation.
>> I will look into it later.
>> Sure. Okay. So, in
terms of parallelism,
so let us say, this is
the high level result.
On the Y axis you'll
see the execution time,
and on the X axis you'll see
the number of processors.
And both of these access
are log scaled.
And the different lines over
here correspond to
different graph sizes.
And as you can see, as
we increase the number
of processors,
the computation time reduces.
And although it is not clear
because this is a log log scale,
it is actually true that as you
increase the number
of processors,
their decrease in competition
time is almost linear.
And finally, just because
we had a framework,
we did this for
a bunch of algorithms
and not just for
one specific example.
And the same result holds
for all of these examples.
So with that, I discuss GraphSC,
where you can take
programs written
in these obstructions of
scatter, gather, and apply.
And you can convert them
efficiently into- and
GraphSC can work
them efficiently into
a parallel execution
using secure computation.
With that, let me move
on to the second part
of my talk on
obfuscating programs.
Don't solve the problem
of achieving
obfuscation is relatively old
and there has been a lot
of approaches to do this.
There have been heuristic
approaches to obfuscation.
For example, this
is one example.
And I have a question for you.
What does this program do?
Or for that matter, what
does this program look like?
Any guesses? I think if
you squint your eyes,
or if you go further
behind, perhaps,
it would be easier. Sorry?
>> It's flappy bird.
>> Yes. So this
is a flappy bird.
So a game that was very famous
I think a couple of years ago.
In terms of, if you
execute this program,
you can play flappy bird
on your dominant.
So, such approaches to
obfuscation tend to
be efficient but they
actually give you no guarantees
on what it obfuscates.
And at the other end it is
known that it is impossible to
achieve software only program
obfuscation in a strong sense.
So given this, we are trying
to come up with a scheme
for obfuscation by using
some other assumptions.
There have been approaches in
cryptography to achieve this.
For example, they
have introduced
this notion of
indistinguishably obfuscation,
which is at this point
inefficient and not
strong enough in practice.
They have introduced this notion
of using secure hardware or
trusted hardware tokens,
but turns out,
most of these schemes use
strong cryptography
primitives such
as fully homomorphic encryption,
or non interactive
zero knowledge proofs,
or they just try to obfuscate
boolean programs
instead of LAN programs.
There have been approaches in
the architecture community but
most of these approaches
are used to hide inputs
and assume public
programs and many of
these Architectural solutions
actually reveal access buttons.
Given that, our goal was to,
our goal in HOP,
which stands for
Hardware makes
Obfuscation Practical,
was to achieve an efficient
obfuscation scheme using
a trusted processor and
the prototype hardware system
to do the same.
In this process, we introduce
some optimizations which
allowed us to perform up
to 240X better than
a baseline scheme while
still being up to 76X lower
than an in secure system.
Before I explain what
our obfuscation scheme is,
let me quickly define exactly
what security properties
we are looking for.
And let us say,
in this ideal world where we
have access to
a trusted third party,
we have Widong who has
a program he would
like to obfuscate.
He wants everyone to use it but
not learn what
this program is doing.
And let us say,
Jonathan is trying to
execute this program
on his own inputs.
So all Jonathan will do,
so all Widong will do is
send this program to
the trusted third party,
and Jonathan will
just send his input to
the trusted third party
which will execute
this and give a result back.
And let's say, in
addition to the output,
it also reveals size
of the program and
some execution time which is
fixed for all inputs
of the same size.
The reason why we're
thinking of Jonathan
as being the
adversary over here,
is because he's the one who's
trying to learn the program.
And in the ideal world,
he never has access to
the program because it
is a trusted third party who
has access to the program.
Jonathan only has an oracle
access to the program.
In the real world, sorry.
And we want this,
he want to ensure this for
all inputs that
Jonathan may have.
In the real world instead,
you have this scenario
where you have
a secure processor
which may have
a small amount of
process storage,
and it stores everything
outside in an encrypted form.
And in this new world,
what you can do is,
Widong can send his program
in an encrypted form
to Jonathan,
and Jonathan can just send
the program and just input
the trusted processor,
and which will perform an
execution with the main memory,
and finally return out.
We're going to assume
that the adversary has
access to this entire memory
all throughout,
and in such a way that he
can modify parts of memory if he
likes because we're envisioning
this competition to be local.
And what you want is the kind of
obfuscation guarantee
that you get to
the left to be the same
as the one on the right.
>> Now who encrypts the input?
>> No one encrypts the input
because it is
the adversary who's
trying to run
this program on his input.
>> I was confused by
the lock on the inputs.
So you're saying, oh,
it's probably that.
>> All right. And also,
assumptions are the form where
such a trusted
processor can store
state in between invocations
actually matters for security.
So first we're
going to assume that
such a trusted processor can
store state in between
invocations that
as we have a stateful processor.
And let us try to construct
an obfuscation scheme
in this scenario.
So whenever some execution is
happening at
every point in time,
the processor is going
to read an instruction.
And this instruction can be
a simple move instruction,
or an arithmetic instruction,
or it can actually
be a memory access.
And whether or not, it
does a memory access
this is something that is
available to the adversary.
So the first thing you would
want to do is you would
want to hide whether it's
a memory access or not.
And one way to do this is to
ensure that for
every non-memory access,
you actually perform
memory accesses with.
Second, based on what
I've been saying earlier,
we would want to protect
our access patterns
and use an oblivious
RAM over here.
Third, because the adversary
has access to the entire memory,
and he can modify parts of it,
your trusted processor would
want to authenticate memory at
all points in time to
ensure that the memory
is not modified.
And it would keep an
authentication token within itself.
And finally, you
would want to run
this program for a fixed time T
for all inputs of
same size just so that
the adversary does not
learn how the program
behaves for different inputs
of the same size.
And this is what I'm
going to refer to as
a baseline scheme later
on in my evaluation.
And it turns out
the few do this,
you will achieve some notion of
obfuscation if you're
running a single application.
If you're running
multiple applications,
let's say, concurrently,
in that case,
the state corresponding to
one program needs
to move out of the
token so that it
can feed it with
the state corresponding
to the other programs.
And such contact switching
motivates the formulation
of a stateless processor.
Okay. A stateless
processor is something
that does not maintain
state between invocations.
So at the end of the invocation,
it will give out an encrypted
state that it stores,
and it would expect
the adversary to send
the state back at
the next invocation.
And if I have such a
stateless processor,
even it's something that
an adversary can do.
He will execute
the first 10 instructions.
And now, it is the turn
of the adversary
to execute the
eleventh instructions.
But the adversary will send
the state corresponding to
the tenth instruction again,
and make the processor
execute the tenth
instruction again.
And based on two executions
of the tenth instruction,
it will try to learn
more information.
And turns out such an attack
which we call a
rewinding attack...
In such an attack
in the scenario,
an adversary can actually
learn information.
And the problem is that,
oblivious RAMs are not secured
against such
rewinding adversaries.
Because I have not explained
an oblivious RAM scheme
as such in this talk,
I will not go into the details
of the exact attack
in model we're here.
But what I will
still give you is in
detail but in precise
explanation of why that happens.
Let us say, my memory location
of interest is
memory location five,
and the two obfuscating accesses
are two, seven and two.
If I rewind execution
and if I run it again,
I still need to access
memory location
five because that is
needed for my [inaudible]
as guarantees,
but the two obfuscating accesses
maybe two to
different locations.
And if I rewind, if I keep
rewinding and if I just perform
a certain to section operation,
then I will exactly know
which memory location
you're accessing.
And although oblivious RAMs
are used to hide
memory access patterns,
we are not achieving
that at all.
>> So remind me
again, why do you want
to contact stateless process?
Is it because you don't want to
assume that
the entire computation
is only one goal the adversary
can put the machine in between?
>> Yes.
>> Why is that
a practical concept?
Like if the adversary
repushed just start
from the beginning and,
like what kind of
programs are you thinking?
Like are you just
allowed any programs?
>> Any program that may
be long running because
such computations
tend to be much
slower than
existing computations.
So if you want to
context switch,
one way to do this is to
ensure that your processor is
stateful and it remembers
context of what's outside.
>> All I need to remember
is who contact, right?
So in case I need to write
my state as [inaudible]
keep track of progress.
>> Yes. Precisely. So if you can
maintain that and if you
have a stateful processor,
well and good, you can do that.
But what we show is that,
even if you do
not remember or if
your processor does not
remember this information,
you can still achieve
the same guarantees.
>> In this specific algorithm,
can you fix it just
by using PRG cable?
>> That is perfect.
>> Are there other attacks
that this doesn't fix? It
doesn't have [inaudible]
>> This fixes it, yeah.
So, specifically
over here we make
sure that adversity commits
to his program and
input ahead of time.
And then, you use
your randomness based on
a pseudo-random function
that depends
on the program and the input.
And in this case,
even if you rewind,
you will still to make sure
that you use the same
obfuscating accesses.
So, with that, I've
explained some of
the key elements involved
in this construction.
Let me move on to
quickly describing
the optimizations and quickly
describing the architecture
of the system.
So, we have two
optimizations over here.
The first optimization
tries to reduce
the number of memory locations
that you're accessing.
And this we need to do because
ORAM accesses tend to be
expensive compared to
a arithmetic instructions.
At a high level over here,
we're just trying to interleave
the number of arithmetic
and memory accesses.
And the second optimization
over here tries to
use a small amount of
trusted storage within
the secured processor.
And if you have programs
that exhibit locality,
you would encode a scratchpad
access instead of
a main memory access.
So, here is what
the architecture of
the system looks like.
We have a secure co-processor,
which works in conjunction
with the host processor,
which is the adversity, and
your data is stored
in an ORAM memory,
which is encrypted.
We started off with
the very local corresponding
to a RISC-V processor,
and we modified this to
include a scratchpad
load instruction,
which was used to fill
the data and
instruction scratchpad.
For an Oblivious RAM,
we used a variant of path
ORAM called Freecursive ORAM,
and this is something
that was built previously.
And finally, we had encryption
and decryption units to
ensure that all the data
outside is stored encrypted.
And here's what the higher
level result looks like.
On the y-axis, you have
Slowdown to Insecure Execution.
And on the x-axis, you
have different programs
that we have implemented.
And the two bars referred to
the baseline scheme and
to our construction.
So, baseline scheme
is something that I
described much earlier and,
HOP is baseline with
the two optimizations.
And the high level result is
that correspondent
to baseline scheme,
we perform up to 240 expected.
And just so that we
can see the y-axis and
Slowdown to Insecure Execution
of HOP clearly,
let me move this to
a logarithmic scale.
So, the y-axis is
now logarithmic.
And the high level
result over here is
that compared to
insecure execution,
we perform in the range
of 8x - 76x HOPs.
So, programs such
as Binary Search,
which exhibit
low degree of locality,
they perform upto 76x HOPs.
But for programs such as
[inaudible] transform,
which have a high degree
of locality,
they perform to 8x HOPs.
With that, I've discussed
a secure obfuscation scheme,
which has been designed
with architectural
constraints in mind.
One key addition that is
necessary in this space is
some programming language
support so that the developer
can easily specify how
to use a scratchpad,
or hopefully, it's
not going to be
the developer's concern on
how the scratchpad is used.
So, with that, I have spoken
about my work on computing on
private data and
obfuscation programs.
Let me try to speak
about my research a
little more in general.
My research has focused
broadly in two areas.
One is on privacy-preserving
computation
and second has been
towards Blockchains.
In privacy-preserving
computation,
I spoke about vandalism in
Oblivious execution and
obfuscated program execution.
In the first section,
I have worked towards
a bunch of papers
on Oblivious RAMs and
Oblivious programs.
For example, I
have worked towards
designing an
Oblivious RAM scheme,
which actually achieves
the Goldriech-Ostrovsky lower
bound although we actually
changed one of the assumptions,
that we assume
our private information
retrieval protocol.
But for the changed assumption,
we show a new
lower bound saying,
you cannot do anything
better even in this scenario.
I've also worked
towards the notion
of having an Oblivious
data structure.
So, let us say,
an adversity already knows
that you just have
a map data structure or
a tree data structure.
And in that case, trying to hide
which operations are being
performed and done so,
these Oblivious data structures
can be faster than a neural.
And finally, I'm presently
looking towards
the notion of achieving
locality in conjunction
with Obliviousness
as well as a notion of achieving
perfect security
with Obliviousness.
In the area of Blockchains,
I have worked towards
adversarial behavior
in Blockchains,
where we have tried to
attack the Bitcoin protocol,
as well as I've worked
towards the design of
a robust Blockchains both in
the permissioned as well
as permissionless settings.
With that, let me move onto
speaking a little bit
about my future work.
The overarching goal
over here is to move
from privacy-preserving
computation
to a privacy-preserving system.
Until now, we have been
discussing having private inputs,
performing some
computation on top of it,
and learning some data models.
For instance, we considered
Netflix ratings as being
approved inputs and
user recommendations
as being the output.
But in an actual system,
you may end up revealing
this information through
other auxiliary means.
For example, if it's
the Netflix's example,
just the fact that you're
streaming movies from
Netflix already tells that
I'm watching this movie.
And that in practice
can hurt you.
Second, the data model itself in
some cases can reveal a lot of
information about
your private inputs.
And if that happens,
the entire privacy-preserving
computation
you're doing in between
is rendered useless.
So, you may want to use
notions of differentiate
privacy in conjunction
with secure computation
to ensure that you still
have some realistic guarantees
on your private inputs.
Second, you'd want to move on
to a broader class
of functions such
as being privacy-preserving
neural networks
or privacy-preserving
genomic tasks,
as also design functions
that are better suited
for secure computation or
that are faster than
secure computation.
Looking at slightly long term,
we would want to
consider alternative
security definitions.
One such example
over here would be,
for Obliviousness, right now,
we are thinking of trying
to hide all access patterns.
But what if we were to think of
Obliviousness as
being a spectrum
between leaking
all access patterns
and hiding all access patterns.
And now, we can try
to pick a point in
between in a way that
you leak some accesses
in such a way that you achieve
some security in
some realistic notion.
The eventual goal over here
is to ensure that a user or
an organization
can specify policy
on how data or
program can be used.
And if all such users
have such a policy,
a company who's
trying to provide
user-specific features actually
adheres to this policy,
and the privacy-preserving
system actually ensures this.
In this space of
robust Blockchains,
I'm interested in
combining the merits of
the classical
consensus protocols
and the new
permissionless protocols,
as well as trying to
achieve the notion of
confidentiality and efficiency
together in Blockchains.
Before ending my talk,
I would like to thank
all of my collaborators
without whom none of
my research would
have been possible.
Thank you. And I'd be
happy to take questions.
>> I've one question.
You said that in
the Netflix experiment,
it took several minutes,
what if for
the unsecured scheme,
how long will it
take in seconds?
>> In case we
implement this now,
for that particular example,
the ratio of secure to
insecure is 10 to the four
with secure computation.
>> About 10?
>> Ten to the four with
secure computation.
>> Ten to the?
>> Ten to the four. So,
what makes one minute,
will take 10,000 minutes.
And if you assume
a trusted processor,
there has been vulnerable [inaudible]
and with the same algorithms,
it is around a factor
of, I think 4,280.
>> So, why do you
think a notion of
non private security like something
[inaudible] is a good idea?
>> Because you'll get
some notion of efficiency.
You're talking about
Obliviousness spectrum?
>> Right, right.
>> So, If you can try
to reduce the number of
accesses or the number
Oblivious accesses,
you'll get some notion
of efficiency.
>> Right. But wouldn't
it be very hard to
define what secure your privacy
really means in that case?
>> That is something that
I'm presently working on,
and trying to understand what
security exactly
means in that context.
You're right. It's
not so easy to define.
So, one notion that can be
interesting is the notion
of traced differentially
private computation,
so that you reveal
some accesses in such a way
that the differential privacy
of users is still maintained.
And that may not be
applicable for all inputs.
So, instead of thinking of
Obliviousness as being
the worst case scenario.
Therefore, any input I'm
going to give you a solution.
If you have let's say, maybe a
distribution on input or
something along those lines,
you're trying to hide
something specific.
Again, I'm not being
very specific here
because this is not
something that I
have thought about entirely,
but this notion seems like
a reasonable one that we
can try to work on.
>> I think that
that's kind is a,
for the approval of obfuscation,
why does it require
Oblivious RAM?
Because this approval
was encrypted even though
the access it's really hard
to reverse engineer
the original program?
>> So, I think a simple example
would be if I have
a program which performs
binary search versus
a program that is adding
elements in an array,
just based on access patterns,
you'll not know exactly
this is what it is doing,
but perhaps you
should be able to
figure out at some point
in time that is
what it is doing.
>> That's only applies to
a very simple program, right?
>> Sure.
I think what we're
trying to get is to able
guarantees with having
a cryptographic proof.
So, you're right.
Even the generic case,
it will be very hard to
actually construct an attack.
But over here, what you're
trying to show is that,
if you have something like this,
you will never be
able to reconstruct
or come up with an attack.
>> Right. There are
real world cases that
people care about
the program obfuscation, right?
And in those real world cases,
is Oblivious RAM unnecessary?
>> So, I would say if
in real world cases,
if they cared about
these settings,
then you would want to
actually hide the program.
And in that case, yes, Oblivious
RAM would be necessary.
>> Okay.
>> So, if you're doing,
never mind. Sorry.
>> Well, it's okay.
I've got you there.
>> Did you have a question?
>> No.
But I can't take here.